salve a tutti e benvenuti in questo
primo blog del nuovo anno del canale ed
è sì perché avendo abbandonato il
secondo canale i blogs dura ri verranno
caricati in questo così non potrete più
fare a meno di me è un po mi dispiace
per voi
comunque quello che volevo dirvi è il 7
el 8 e 9 marzo ci sarà
mantova comics giusto 7 8 9 e in
particolare le 8 marzo sarò ospite
dell'area blogger in compagnia di files
dario moccia e daniele doesn't matter
quindi se non avete nessuna donna cui
fare gli auguri siete i benvenuti ma
niente mimose già l'anno scorso avevo
chiesto per scherzo portate preservativi
e me ne avete portati quindi riproviamo
anche quest'anno e questa volta voglio
un milione di dollari in banconote da 10
in una valigetta è un biglietto di sola
andata per la polonia
se possibile entro mezzanotte grazie
oppure un pacchetto di marshmallow e del
tè alla pesca come volete voi
la prima opzione è la migliore comunque
in descrizioni c'è link al sito così
avrete tutte le informazioni secondo
perché da un mese a questa parte non ci
sono più video bel avevo già circa
spiegato non e con un blog del canale di
gameplay e mi sento di dovere di
spiegarvi il perché
perché questo ritardo è anche grazie a
voi sono in città a censirne calcate non
è vero sono ingrassato un pochino solo
perché mi piacciono i muffin al
cioccolato fondente si vide sul ritardo
per causa vostra perché ho trovato casa
ormai lo sapete youtube è parte
integrante della mia vita e non solo e
diciamo che quest'anno ha voluto puntare
un po di più su youtube è infatti è un
mese che non faccio video e quindi ho
deciso di fare il salto della fede di
prendere casa dopo varie ricerche ho
trovata e ci vuole molto più tempo del
previsto per adesso abitare nel senso
adesso è tutto quasi finito la questione
di una settimana e siamo lì io e la mia
signorina martina ma non è proprio come
nei telefilm 9 wow
questa casi della la prendo calci ming e
stacco di inquadrature loro sono già
livelli a dormire sulle
e tutto arredato tutto perfetto in due
secondi qui un po diverso tipo
wow che bella questa casa aspetti devi
fermare qua qua qua qua guardi che deve
fare l'allaccio della luce del gas o
guardi che ci sono le blatte poi qui
tutta l'acqua calda è un po un casino da
far funzionare deve chiamare l'idraulico
poi leggermente da mettere a posto
insomma al frigorifero ed a cambiare per
e abitabile e se ne rimane un po di
tempo per suicidarsi è tutto grasso che
cola
quindi ripetere queste di massimo un
paio di settimane e sono pronto per
ricominciare con talmente tanti video
che mi verrete a trovare sotto casa con
dei mattoni forati a spaccarmi le tempie
se volete chiudere il video adesso
chiudetelo perché io adesso vi ringrazio
questo inizio anno è stato un po caotico
tra il nuovo format la casa lavoro è
stato una bella scimmia da tenere sulle
spalle ma se sono riuscito a fare questo
passo è anche grazie a voi che
continuate a seguirmi dopo tutti questi
anni il fatto che avevo cambiato format
è il fatto che riusciate a sopportare me
che faccio video con questa barba
ignobile insomma questo mio viaggio non
è un vero viaggio se non lo facciamo
insieme quindi grazie per farmi vivere
in parte facendo quello che mi piace
spero che quest'anno spacchi cui a tutti
gli altri anni che ho passato su youtube
poi the fair mostarda o idee per
cortometraggi o idee per nuovi serio
idee per nuove recensioni che comunque
una volta ogni magari tre mesi usciranno
e non è che lo proprio uccise e se per
caso non dovesse andare bene il capitolo
casa potete sempre per il mia trovare
del po più vicino mi riconoscete perché
sono quello che lotterà con i gatti per
l'ultimo pezzettino di tondo pensa se
accade per la vero